اما ميخائيل بدويات كمستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني فقال انه مفاوضات السلام يمكن
ان تبدا عندما تخرج روسيا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله وفقه واعتبر بدليات في
تصريحات للجزيره ان بلاده هي وحدها من
تتحدث عن مفاوضات السلامه الحقيقيه
للتخلي عن مطالبها من المهم فهموا ان
روسيا لا تريد مفاوضات السلام
فهي تذكر كلمه المفاوضات لتحصل على مهله
العمليه بينما تدرب الاحتياطيين وتشتري
الاسلحه لا يوجد اي اهتمام لروسيا
بالمفاوضات بل تريد تحقيق انتصارات
العسكريه في الحرب وتثبيتها لذلك تواصل
اوكرانيا عمليتها الهجوميه المضاده
لذلك قال بدليات للجزيره لابد من ان تتدخل
روسيا في محادثات السلام حتى تخفف من اثار
الخساره وحتى لا تغرق في مشاكل داخليه
كبيره على حد تعبيره
الغرق في مشاكل الداخليه كبيره فعليها
قبول دعوات اوكرانيا وصيغتها للسلام
كبدايه لمفاوضات السلامه
اهتماما كبيره
غير موثوق به ولا يمكنها تنفيذ عقودها ولا
بيع اسلحتها ولا تستطيع دعم احد على
المستوى الدولي